Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman.
This is absolutely great.
A viewer left a voicemail.
And it is a parody of Eric from Massachusetts,
Eric from Massachusetts is a guy who's been
calling me for the entire pandemic, saying,
David, you're going to end up in prison thanks
to the vaccine stuff that you're promoting
on your show.
So here is a parody of Eric from Massachusetts.
Then I'll play for you the real Eric from
Massachusetts.
Speaker 8: Hey, David, this is Chris from
Mass.
Hey, I mean, I hate it.
I hate to break it to you, David.
I mean, I told you, I mean, these vaccines
are just like, you know, they don't work.
I mean, I live here in Massachusetts.
We have one of the highest vaccination rates
in the country.
And you consistently the lowest rate of hospitalizations
in the lowest rate of deaths and the lowest
rate of infections.
I mean, these vaccines, Damons, they just
don't work.
You should be arrested and imprisoned for
all of the misinformation.
That is right.
Speaker 1: All right.
So that's pretty spot on.
And as a reminder, here's the real Eric from
Massachusetts with his admonishments to me.
Speaker 8: Hey, David, if they're from Mars,
Speaker 1: I'm very similar, I have to say
Speaker 8: this, wondering a few things on
your videos.
Earlier, you were touting the vaccines that
they're all this 98 percent effective, this,
that and the other, and now everyone else
should get it vaccinated.
But if I don't do admitting I mean, seriously,
think about this.
Aren't you admitting that the vaccines don't
work?
If you're saying everyone else needs them?
I mean, just think about that.
Speaker 1: No, that's been the case with every
vaccine.
I mean, when you take the measles vaccine,
the measles vaccine is very effective.
But measles is so contagious that you really
need almost everybody to be vaccinated.
We understand these things.
It's simple math.
We are now learning about immunity waning
over time.
These things are not unexpected.
Yeah, but it's this guy is really obsessed
with this stuff.
Speaker 8: I mean, if you have a better way
of telling people, me and everyone explain,
explain why.
If they work so well, like everyone else should
do
Speaker 1: it because nothing is 100 percent
and there are actually people who can't get
the vaccine, including right now, everybody
under 12.
So we do it because we care about other people,
but we need people to be team players.
It's like, how are we in September of twenty,
twenty one?
Still not understanding this, Eric.
Speaker 8: I mean, I just if you can convince
me that, you know what I'm going to show you
can convince me of a reason that I should
get it when it's obviously not working.
I'll get it.
Speaker 1: OK, Eric, the problem is you're
saying I'll get vaccinated if you convince
me of something you either refuse to accept
or won't understand.
Because at this point in September of twenty
twenty one, I don't know.
I don't know what else could possibly be done
or said that.
Let me put it that way.
We're going to have a great bonus show today
on the bonus show today.
We are going to talk about is it true that
when it's a missing white girl like Gabby
Petito, there is more news attention paid
then when it is a nonwhite girl or woman?
OK, we're going to talk about that on today's
show.
We have data, we have math, we have stats.
All right.
We are also going to talk today on the bonus
show about the House bill that would blow
up the huge IRAs of the super wealthy.
We've talked before in the context of how
the hell did Mitt Romney get so much money
in his IRA when you can only contribute a
few thousand bucks a year?
How do you do it?
We're going to talk about the House bill that
would change that.
And lastly, Amazon is now lobbying the US
government to make pot legal.
What's in it for them?
I will explain it to you.
It's actually quite interesting.
All of those stories that I just mentioned
and more are on today's bonus show.
The bonus show is available instantly for
everybody who signs up at Join Pakman Dotcom
or makes a pledge of at least five bucks a
month on Patreon at Patreon Dotcom Slash David
Pakman show.
Sign up and we will see you on the bonus.